hey people it's me again with another
memorializing story
uh you know um
i was thinking about life the other day
and i was thinking about
how
god created everything
with different sides he made it up and
it down he made it right he made it left
he made it positive he made it negative
i'm going somewhere with this let me let
me get started anyway
i was thinking about where i
when i started coming here and like why
why i come here and uh uh
and do these these the talks that i do
and tell you the reality of what's going
on in my life and that's that's some
real [ __ ] that'd be going on
i was in el paso texas one time
god here i go it's just this is hard and
hard to get out i was in el paso texas
one time
and that bought me a dub y'all know
smoke y'all know what it does about me
and i'm sitting there behind behind the
shaky pizza and all i see was a little
white legs come walking down the street
i saw some some converse chin and shoes
and some pretty white legs so my old
show looked pretty today she turned
around and said oh thank you
what are you doing i said well i'm
sitting here smoking go away
what is that oh come on over i'll show
it to you
she comes over she takes a hit i take it
i look at her she wanna go she she says
wow that stuff makes you feel good all
over i said does i said you want to go
somewhere and do something she said i
don't care so we go around the back of
the building
and i proceeded to try to have sex with
this girl
and i looked at her looked at her real
good i said how old are you
she said i'm 14 years old
now i like to tell you that i said put
your pants back on you too [ __ ] young
for me to [ __ ] with i proceeded to do
that [ __ ] any guy that way and i
remember when i had done that [ __ ]
it affected me in a way
but when i under under the influence i
didn't give a [ __ ] when you i was i was
in all of that [ __ ] i didn't give up but
i did that
and it but i i bogged down i bogged down
that's something that i bogged down
and uh it's hard me to release that [ __ ]
but i had to release it today
i know that in releasing this [ __ ] i
like i said y'all can take in process do
what the hell you won't do it but it's
i'm getting up off of it because it's
something in some ways helping me
and um
i'm gonna talk about one more thing that
i did
this is the worst worse worse worse
my best friend
my best friend
many a year a
million a year
he was getting married i was to be the
best man
y'all said they saw me i pulled up in
the in the white lincoln continental i
had to shoot on i was going they had the
ring ready for me i had i was all suited
and booted i was looking real god damn
good i was a real guy
it was about an hour before the ceremony
first start we're in the hotel and
somebody slipped me an envelope
i don't know i didn't know what was in
here but i took the [ __ ] everybody
upstairs and put it in the pocket around
the jeez i had on and took my sugar and
then didn't think about it as i was
walking down the stairs
something told me well go back up there
and see what they gave you
they gave me 700
700 100 bills to split between me and in
the group
on the way down the stairs now we get
ready to go to the sherman on the way
down the stairs
my head said the dope man is two blocks
away
if i just go down there and get one
[ __ ] 20 if i just get one [ __ ] 20
and blow that 20 and come back well i'll
be high and the whole thing the whole
ceremony will there
i went and got the 120
and then there's a girl there at the
dope house and i got a girl
next thing i know
is
three days later
and i go back
to where the ceremony was supposed to be
and was wondering where the [ __ ]
everybody was
this is my best friend
i humanity myself
my friends
my family
his family to this day
they they never said nothing that they
never said they never said a goddamn
word to me
and that [ __ ] hurts hurts like a
[ __ ] every time i think about it
but i did that [ __ ]
you know due to this crazy ass drug and
alcohol thing
i'm gonna talk about
my alcoholism my drug condition
i was
23 years old
my father threw me in a
drug treatment program
and the first thing
that people told us we were all in the
group of walls and around a group of
people
he said
as i count two people two stand up two
sit down two stand up two sit down two
stand up two sit down it was two people
standing out of 40 people he said only
two of y'all
gonna [ __ ] stay sober i said whoa
whoa whoa homeboy wait wait what the
[ __ ] i raised my no hold on mother hold
on hold on how the [ __ ] you gonna tell
these people we're gonna we gonna i said
it's all [ __ ] i don't wanna be a
[ __ ] man y'all y'all bullsh y'all y'all
know what you're talking about this [ __ ]
ain't got that much control of all of us
if we all gonna realize why the hell we
in here
you don't know what the hell you talking
about so
as i so i left the program and within
the years
i'm not lying if not all of them i know
i saw four of them out there out back
out there on the streets
bri literally i said what the [ __ ] i
became i became homeless for the first
time i wasn't i was out by the beach and
i became i was i became hope this was
this was disgrace to me this was
something that was something that i'm
homeless and you know where i came from
i had a job in a car you know what a
beautiful woman you know that jury and
[ __ ] what the [ __ ]
they told me that they told me that they
told me that i was i had to realize that
i was powerless over drugs and alcohol
if i was going if i was going to ever
change i was going to ever do anything
which didn't make no damn sense to me
so
let me tell you what i did
i i gotta i'll stay sold for a little
while i got i got my first check
i [ __ ] it all off
i swore that i would never ever ever
ever ever ever ever ever ever ever do
that [ __ ] again
i did that [ __ ] the next week so i kind
of saw some some i said well maybe maybe
i do have a problem
when
when when when they told me that my
daughter wasn't coming home because she
had drugs in her system
that traumatized me
when when when
i couldn't i just couldn't get a grip
i told
i'm going to tell how i realized that
i'm powerless i told my family my girl
and everybody that
next friday
i'm not if if i know if i take if i know
if i take one [ __ ] drink
i'm gonna [ __ ] the whole damn world up
when i take a drink
it's like i'm like the tasmanian devil
[ __ ] just
see everything flying around me and they
go shoot look at my daughter they want a
baby and they got my job take all my
money flying in there
goddamn average [ __ ] i ain't
never doing that [ __ ] again
two days later
i'm gonna took a drink and i'm [ __ ] up
again so i said wait a minute
if i just if i just if if i if i just
whenever i've been trying to do this
[ __ ]
because i was 22 years old and i'm damn
near 60 and just not realizing the [ __ ]
i got to surrender because i'm dumb i'm
powerless over this [ __ ] [ __ ] man
i walked by
the liquor store
and schwartz with everything with
everything every everything in me i
meant what i said when i told everybody
i'm not gonna [ __ ] go to i'm not
gonna drink no one and i
with everything i had in me i was i was
honest i was honestly saying i was
honest about that
i passed the [ __ ] liquor store and i
made that left turn instead of making it
right i did that [ __ ] way back then and
i think the other i think about a month
ago
i had some money
and i
i have an apartment there's no [ __ ]
linen on my bed i got there's no there's
no [ __ ] in my bed
every [ __ ] month i say i'm going to
walk up to the big the big market and
get the [ __ ] linen every time i start
to walk that way
for some reason i said well let me go
stop and get a beer first one once i get
a [ __ ] beer
all bits are all
if i if if i have an engagement
something that's supposed to happen in
my life or
somewhere i'm supposed to be or
something i'm supposed to do
and with all sincerity i'm i'm all
sincerity i'm going i actually think
that i'm gonna be there
once i take a [ __ ] drink
oh
[ __ ] up i don't know where i'm end up i
don't know how i'm gonna be three days
later i'm i'm coming too i'm sick of
some [ __ ] dog
and i got to figure out another goddamn
lie about
what i did i had i i had a girlfriend
one time the poor girl
she made the mistake she made the
mistake of getting a joint bank account
with me i said oh [ __ ]
that's it
some wanted me to tell her baby you
don't want to break a cat with me
because i'm i might [ __ ] up i might [ __ ]
up
three days later
vlogging i go i go skiing i go i'm going
to scan 20 hours off the [ __ ]
topic she don't know i just take two out
of the time well by the time five five
days later i just gave him two or three
hundred dollars off to them out of their
bank i said oh [ __ ]
maybe she'll never find out
and the poor lady she had kids yeah i
mean oh she had kids man
when
she got in the car one day she looked at
me i i i knew she knew
she said when i get back in this
[ __ ] car
you're going to tell me where the [ __ ]
my money is that man i'll never forget
the shame
the humidity the embarrassment the the
the just just just the
the way i felt now i feel so so empty so
odd
you know i i i went to i went to i went
to a
to a lakers game one time i knew if i
went to the lakers game
and i remember sitting there and
everybody was having fun and all happy
and i've been sitting there feeling so
empty so ugly so dirty behind all these
things i'm telling you that i did so so
all this [ __ ] and every time i did
something like that it would it would it
would
it would be more pain and build more
pain and build more pain so as i come
here and talk about [ __ ]
make me feel a little bit a little bit a
little bit better
but through that through the alcohol ism
and and the drug condition
somebody came to my house
a couple of weeks ago and i don't even
know i don't even well i didn't have
nothing to do i don't know about no
crystal they made me do some crystal
meth whatever that [ __ ] was and god damn
it
knocked me out and took took my phone
took all my [ __ ] out my goddamn house
you know uh it's not my you know just
took off a lot of [ __ ] out of my house
you know and me being under the
influence just me being powers you know
i never did no [ __ ] like that you want
to try this now i never can't say no you
want to try it's not so i you know i i
just i did all that goddamn tips and i
got i got depressed
and god bless my family my family they
they they don't they don't they don't my
family they don't respect me at all
they don't respect me they they stay
shut me they
they don't verbally say it but i'm i'm i
can cycle the needle they don't bump me
around
they think that i'm just they think that
they think that i do what i do because i
do because i want to be defiant because
i want to be evil because i want to be
what i do and i do because i'm powers
and that's just that that's just a
goddamn truth
uh
i am a [ __ ]
this
i ain't never i got to say this [ __ ] out
loud i'm a [ __ ] junkie
and a [ __ ] alco when i sat
there one day with all that [ __ ] on that
[ __ ] table and looking at them with
the bottles i said i'm up something
something real wrong with me
a [ __ ] straight i remember when
i was a little kid we saw this movie
they were trying to teach us you know
kids this is where you're gonna end up
when if you do this [ __ ] this is where
you're going to end up you're going to
be here not me oh no no no no no not not
to lose nothing not louis louis
everything no i'm not going to be like
y'all might have that [ __ ] i'm
not going to blame [ __ ]
i remember seeing all my friends worried
that we were all young
one of my
brother's best friends his son is a
professional as a professional
basketball player i remember running up
with his dad
and i remember thinking his dad was
going i remember seeing his dad coming
up coming down the alley drunk i
remember seeing him in my car he threw
up in my car drunk and i was thinking to
myself why am i hanging with these
people these people gonna grow me these
people won't grow up and be junkies now
college not me i don't want to hang on
to people all those guys are all my
friends are very very successful i'm the
only one who ended up with all this
goddamn
this drug and alcohol problem
so
this [ __ ] this [ __ ] this [ __ ] has gotten
so out of hand you know it's like when i
i get so goddamn depressed until
i get like it's the feelings of of
depression you know and [ __ ] it just it
eats me alive it just it eats my life
and i don't have no friends i don't have
no girlfriend
all right no friends no girl no nobody
so i sit there in the house
you know when i can't talk to nobody
this is this is a problem
when you go through all this [ __ ] what
makes you so bad is you don't have
nobody to talk to because you know i
don't trust nobody i'm not going to tell
you my [ __ ] the only reason i sat down
here because i said well hell i said
well i'm sitting here they can't they
can see me but they can't see me they're
not looking at my face so i can actually
get off of this [ __ ] and i don't give a
damn they say look this is what i
i'm going somewhere i figured what
nobody never know what nobody ever see
me they see me on on the camera but
they'll never they'll never see me on
the street they'll never see me here and
then
oh no i didn't know the people anyway
i was um
i was i was
walking down the street coming home one
day
the guy says
louis can i get a light
and i didn't think about what he said oh
no i left my lighter home dude and i'm
walking i get two blocks down the road
i said what the f when
what you call me louis how you know my
name i watch he said this he said we
he said we watch you on youtube all the
time
well what the [ __ ] and it's it's still
not clear they're still not it's not
it's not not registering that that
people are actually listening to this
[ __ ] because i'm thinking anybody who am
i'm just a loser i'm just a dumb bum
loser drug addict [ __ ] who don't
listen to me on this [ __ ] mic
so
i was
here's where i'm going
i was gonna stop
i said
why am i coming down here
telling all my business like a
[ __ ] fool these people oh i
can't believe i'm i'm not going down
why this is my why i kept i was
wondering why am i doing it
why
i got all these problems why am i doing
this
i got on the [ __ ] bus
i'm gonna be this
when i get on the bus i looked i looked
to the right side and there's this lady
there and she keeps looking at me
what the [ __ ]
and it's it's it's making me [ __ ]
let me tell you the story
when i sit on the back of the bus here
comes this big fat basement hey luis
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you man how
the hell are you gonna look at them you
get on the national tv and you tell all
your [ __ ] business your [ __ ] [ __ ]
man you don't do no [ __ ] like that then
you're a coward do some [ __ ] after
he said it loud in front of everyone i
must hurt him i'm sitting on the back of
the bus now he's he hasn't seen the show
now i like to tell you that i got up and
beat his [ __ ] ass
i'd like to tell you that that i took
off myself and said hey man don't be
talking you know i did how dare you talk
to me like that
i sat there like a bit and i
because
that's how i was feeling that's how i
was feeling for doing this [ __ ]
so i was i said damn that's confirmation
i know i don't need to go
now here comes the lady on the other
side
she said louis
i see the [ __ ] on the on the youtube too
i got more respect for you as a man
than any man i ever met for you to get
up there and do that
she said i'm gonna tell you you i got
utmost respect she said you a real man
you got balls man you get up there to
the height you you know how to special
feelings
let me let me see
and i said i said i looked at her i said
well thank you ma'am she said
i was sitting in a car
looking at you on youtube and my old man
was sitting next to me in your passenger
seat
you spoke about
being molested you spoke about pushing
that [ __ ] down
and she said he got the most peculiar
look on his face
and she said i looked at him and said
what's wrong baby
he
said same thing happened to me
and i've been holding that [ __ ] in and
when i heard him he said
he started to cry
he started to cry when i heard him say
it
so she said you don't know who you
affected she said because when they came
up with him he's coming up in a hold of
other people too
he said you take your ass back over
there you keep on doing what you're
doing
so
now that's what i was talking about
that's why i was going with the negative
and the positive because
the positive about all this this
negative [ __ ] i see
my problems are what my problems are
what i come here with
but i'm in my solution i always wonder
what's my solution my solution is doing
what i'm doing now
sharing it so i'm helping somebody else
with that [ __ ] somebody could come
somebody said well damn
i did the same thing and i knew and i'm
in a hole in mine ain't goddamn if he
could talk about he's maybe i need to
talk about mine so my school i feel like
so when when she said it about i feel
like i
i feel i feel real good i feel like i
feel like that purpose in life now so
now i gotta have i can take all this
negative [ __ ]
and turn it into a positive and just
tell it until i get the idea so i'm glad
i came here with the truth because
normally i would've
my my whole hope was to come here and
lie
but like i say i threw the truth out on
the float because i needed to get off of
that [ __ ] i needed to tell somebody that
[ __ ] because i thought i was the only
[ __ ] in the world who was that
weak and stupid in that coyote to let
this [ __ ] affect me like that i was the
only [ __ ] who did to all this
with all this who did all this dirt with
all this stupid [ __ ] you know and then
i mean
for me to see just about once every
other week somebody hey look
at me i knew it and who would [ __ ]
all these goddamn people
i became
some kind of way of slavery i've never
i've never been i'm i've never in my
life been popular nowhere and i wouldn't
say i'm powerful i mean i'm like people
actually know me i'm like as much of a
loser as i am people [ __ ] know me
what's up let me give me some dap [ __ ]
what's up
i'll be so happy to say i'll be so happy
for somebody to know me like yeah
somebody know me now i'm somebody now so
i just started coming here and while
that lady made me that was happy that
was the happiest day of my life
when that one told my roommate
that they were they were actually
sitting in the [ __ ] car looking on
the phone he heard me
talk some of this [ __ ] and he had went
through the same thing so he had been
pushing you know
so i'm
what
glad
[ __ ] was the right for the people who
don't want to hear this [ __ ] like this
guy hey you put your wooden
i'm not doing it for you
i'm doing it for that guy
who's
outside sitting in his car watching this
[ __ ] on youtube scared to go in the
house
because he got to tell us a month that's
his wife you know [ __ ] all [ __ ] off
all this money again i didn't done that
[ __ ] i had to sit in the car waiting on
the waiting on the wife and kids to go
to bed because i couldn't i feel so
ashamed i couldn't go in and say so i
didn't want her to say where's the money
where's the money because i ran out of
lies
i ran out of [ __ ] eyes i just had to
come clean up [ __ ] it off i'm an addict
you know that that's the hardest the
hardest thing in the world to do it
admit that [ __ ]
so you know now i'm just working on
trying to working on working on my
solution
when i'm when i'm when i'm there when
i'm in the bush and i'm in the bush and
when i'm living here i'm living in a
solution and i hope that young ladies
looking i sure appreciate you you made
my day
i'm back
so i'm lewis and i see you all in next
year
thank you